with every day in mariopol it becomes
ever more horrific
filmed by journalists from the
associated press on tuesday this is
putin's war
a city besieged a hospital overwhelmed
doctors doing everything they can for
survivors who hold on just
and all around images of a hell that is
hard to comprehend
dr valerie drenga wants the world to see
all this
there is no morgue in this hospital they
just have the basement
and with the torch of his phone he
reveals the three bundles
the newborn he says
i don't know when he was brought in and
this one the day before yesterday all of
them were injured they arrived but we
could not save them
he unbundles one
it is an image we have seen but one
which we cannot broadcast
in a conflict where such cruelty is then
compounded by accusations of fake news
he shows the truth
we must get used to it dr valerie says
but then in the evening you can't take
it out of your mind
all we know about the baby is that she
was 22 days old and her family name
panasenkov
that all the hospitals have been bombed
he says no one could collect them no
emergency services no relatives nobody
i don't know where we will put them how
we will bury them i have no idea he says
it's russian he's speaking most in this
city are russian speakers
and that adds to all of this putin is
killing people whose language is the
same whose culture is so close
back upstairs the corridor is the
waiting room the ward the operating room
no supplies are getting to this hospital
to the city they are running out of
everything the young survivors had
already been moved from the bombed
maternity ward now they lie under
blankets to protect them from the flying
glass as the explosions continued
[Music]
help she says it is a city residential
buildings help mariopol
children women are being killed
hospitals are overcrowded we're all here
for what i don't understand genocide
the local officials here say they have
counted two and a half thousand dead now
but many more have not been tallied or
buried in the mass graves it is too
dangerous and it goes on
and on
mark stone sky news in neighboring
moldova